what's up guys i'm noah back and i'm
here with buzzfeed to read some thirst
tweets
noah beck is the hottest man on earth i
just want to kiss him and hug him and
tell him that he is so hot i think we
can all agree that he is the hottest man
on earth so cute and sexy yummy
nice
battle
she really emphasized on the hottest man
on earth she said it like three times
thank you to whoever said that so in
this house we think that noabek is the
most handsome man to ever exist are you
coming in they got creative with this
one okay they made like a house on top
of another house or that might be a
chimney it was very nice
by saying handsome it's respectful i can
only imagine how much thursday they'll
get i'd be happy to come in if they're
catering any kind of food i would let
noah beck make my scoliosis worse yeah
that's an interesting one i mean
scoliosis is a serious issue and i don't
want to like make that any worse i can
only imagine that back problems would
that even
i don't know how to play on that but no
i don't want to i don't want to touch
your scoliosis so
moving on no bet could hit me in the
face with a toaster and caused permanent
scarring and i would thank him for his
time
yeah i wouldn't do that i i wouldn't hit
anyone with the toaster but uh if i did
apparently she would thank me so that's
good to know not to sound dramatic but i
would let noah beck run me over with a
double-decker bus and i would say thank
you again i wouldn't be doing these
things but if i were to it's nice to
know that people would appreciate it
novak should do the walk dance on top of
me you know with the dance there's like
a lot of steps there's like a lot of
choreography and i'm like playing the
wap dance like in my head and how it
would go i don't think i could do that
on top of anyone because it involves
like a kick and then like it involves me
having to go on the ground
ah fair enough i could see where she
would want me to
do it on top of her okay i would let
noah beck hit me with a semi and i would
pay for the gas to do it
very similar to the the previous two
who's getting the semi noah beck is the
only man's
jesus
noah beck is the only man's ass i would
a thousand percent eat
thanks for throwing the offer out
respectfully i'm gonna have to say no to
that offer jesus
nobeck needs his ass a asap that's why i
stay on twitter for the most part um but
it's uh
twitter seems like an interesting place
people are really out there with their
information you know take talk it's a
little bit more subtle with like the
comments not true not true at all no
tick tock they're pretty out there as
well noah beck is the new owner of this
[ __ ]
that we're so funny i immediately
thought badessy but um is it a boy [ __ ]
i just know from she like bae why it
smell like but disney booty put out that
one his boy [ __ ] okay boyfriend gotcha
no becca's new owner of this [ __ ] i
would
i would like him to film me
hashtag
2021 goals good to shoot for the stars
good to have goals and aspirations
that's it's amazing it's manifestation
right there
i would let noah beg put both sets of
fingers in
redacted and then pull him apart as
protected and then i would redacted
until he was enacted and we were both
reacted and then i would redacted his
milk
i don't know how to take this like i'm
flattered at the end of the day like
thanks
both sets of fingers initially when i
read this i first thought like both
fingers and i was like
maybe reasonable but both sets of
fingers uh
no this looks like the last one um i
dragged my ball sack that's full of [ __ ]
across 100 000 nails just to lick the
inner thighs of goddess noah back oh my
god we'll move on um then if he'd let me
i'd lick his feet clean and suck his
toes until i
bust a nut from enjoyment
that is all smiley face so to the point
so uh he really drew a clear image in my
head of what he would do to lick my
thighs drag a ball sack that's all come
across a thousand nails it's a bit
excessive i mean at the end of the day
like you get it together man that is all
i like that that as well that's funny i
like that little touch at the end yeah
well that was the last one so this has
been fun thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you buzzfeed for
having me and reading these thirst
tweets make sure you guys go watch my
new season of my show nobody tries
things on awesomeness tv
[Music]
you